welcome back to the universe so today I
want to look at tidal forces which I
hear are in the game and might be kind
of cool to see in action at the moment
I've got up a earth and moon system and
this should be a pretty accurate
representation of how far away the moon
is from the earth and so what aren't
tidal forces well a tidal force is
essentially the impact of a larger body
say the earth gravitationally on a
smaller body that's orbiting around it
say the moon so the earth would exert a
stronger gravitational pull on the side
of the moon that is facing it then on
the side of the moon that is away from
it and this would set up sort of a a
potential or a difference across the
moon in terms of that gravitational
force and if that tidal force is strong
enough it can
fix the moon's rotation it can cause
stress within the moon which would heat
it up and if it's large enough it could
actually rip the moon to shreds there's
a certain point where these sort of
tidal forces would be enough to rip
another body apart and that's called the
rush limit so if the moon wants to be a
lot closer to and within the Roche limit
we would actually see the moon being
ripped apart by those extreme stresses
that are gravitationally sort of exerted
upon it tidal forces are also one of
them kind of lots of the rotation of the
moon in the sense that there's always
one side facing us or the same side and
that's the moon rotates on its axis
almost the same amount of time that it
takes to go around the earth so tidal
forces sort of they do have an impact on
orbits and rotations of other bodies
now what I want to do is move the moon
closer and we already have a simulation
we've got this estimate close and and
see what happens if we are within that
limit
this is that 20 minutes the second slow
it down a little bit so you can actually
see it getting really hot kind of rocks
flying off it but we're on the dioxide
now but um yeah the the moon is
definitely healing a lot of stress from
being this close to this and well the
moon did use to be a lot closer to us
and anything this is something that
we're going to have to actually worry
about in the future because the earth I
think is moving very slightly further
away from the earth
every year and not closer so we're not
going to suddenly run into this
situation I wonder if these smaller
moons will then start to break up all
that yep that one's already starting to
go
so I guess that some as it's decreased
in size still exhibit it's gotten closer
and it still got forces on it such that
it the the force of gravity from the
earth is stronger than the force of
gravity actually holding this blob
together in the first place and so yeah
it's just a component
I know we can have a look at a
simulation with more than one closed
moon in fact we can look at earth with
eight sort of satellites around it so
these little moon looking things here
are eight copies of a dwarf planet Ceres
some of these are going to be close
enough to be within the rush limit and
we'll probably see them implode as well
some of them might be lucky enough to
escape that we're going twenty minutes a
second again
as well as affecting things like orbits
[Music]
destroying things affecting like sort of
rotation and what we see these tidal
forces can also affect planetary
atmospheres and sort of the temperature
of a planet because before it implodes
or you even saw in that last simulation
the earth was sort of heating up quite a
lot and these fragments are going to be
getting quite hot as well so I think you
can try to consider things like tidal
forces and terraforming a planet or in
trying to work out maybe something's
really far away from the star but maybe
it's got enough tidal forces acting upon
it that it's temperature is not
negligent well those were some of the
pre-made and simulations that
get a blank slate now
and I want to see
obviously tidal forces you're gonna see
on any massive object so that should
apply for the earth they should apply
for stars but also to the most massive
thing I can think of right now
and that would be a black hole well we
can have Sagittarius a I think that's
the black hole pretty close to us or at
least it's the only one I know by name
anyway we've got to add a few objects
here and see how they're affected by the
tidal forces
so let's put our son in here put him at
that sort of event horizon level yeah
and and maybe if you say that let's see
not sure how far we need to go to see no
effect I think all these sons are going
to start to over the black hole
hopefully some of them will survive
spaghettification okay all right
well I'm not sure what kind of hands
down I'm gonna need to see anything here
but let's just click
[Music]
okay okay
immediately we're getting a root de pod
here and it's happening to everyone
except this guy so that's a really cool
sort of interstellar light simulation of
this black hole here
all right let's go to our closest Sun
that was kind of at that event horizon
distance well I mean some of it still
exists we didn't run for very long move
back down to like 20 seconds per second
okay yeah so it's getting stretched it's
getting like the material ripped from
both sides of it and it's just having
that done while it starts to orbit
around that black hole and looks like a
similar story this
seems to be alright not sure for how
long but for now he's good
so even the Sun is not immune to tiny
forces
back up
so it kind of seems like some of these
sons are actually starting to look less
bad like let's go have a look over here
that's no longer spaghettified it's
seemingly still cool the Sun
hey I don't know how excuse me how do I
open this maybe
I'm guessing that's lost quite a bit of
mass there okay so it's now 127 times
Jupiter I mean that seems smaller than
what we started with let's have a look
over here though okay these messages
actually come down to quite small these
are just listed in terms of kgs now so
actually they still look vaguely
sun-like but oh yeah they've lost a lot
of mass in this process and they are
just getting ripped to pieces even this
one out here 462 Jupiter
I'll put back down another Sun just to
see what that would have said initially
again and that gives it intended and
once all ms so everything here is
started to lose mass as it orbits this
black hole I guess it's gonna swim
slowly dwindle down to just be a
fragment
well they're off today I do what else
can we add it when we've got plenty of
other stars I wonder if these are rated
by mass this one a lot bigger
actually he's any in amount of Jupitus
so give him by the fact that he's
already obliterated I don't think he was
much more message
hit and small message here here we have
all right Sirius is 2 times the Sun 21
times a samurai j'l
the viven times let's go to Rigel Rigel
and just put him in here okay he's
pretty big yeah
it's pretty I put them pretty far away
to see how he's been faking by this
oh yeah okay that's pretty cool he's
been whoa okay he was obliterated in a
puff of smoke
oh my gosh I said amygdala oh my god
oh is what a riot but I do like so we
put down earlier he's also being
[Music]
being slowly obliterated I wonder if
we'll see a cloud of puff from them too
okay so what are we had all down here
fragments just fragments and gradual
that's really cool our sums are still in
there
oh so this is a supernova day we get so
those title forces were enough to turn
Rigel into a supernova well I'll believe
it if the game says so it has pretty
impressive
well it's funny like um isn't a
supernova of a dying star one way that
you can form a black hole in the first
place so I wonder if tidal forces from a
black hole would be able to turn another
massive dying star into a second black
hole I mean let me know if you have any
idea let's just let's just go full out
with the ride rules I want to see that
supernova in any one happier than Mirage
Olivia
[Music]
as soon as all these arms look big
okay 260 of the Sun that should be
catastrophic
let's put him in here okay
it's doing all right
Sterne okay he's pretty far away so
again it since the slow demise what if
we put him in a little closer
[Music]
well at least I can see the black hole
now since the sky is so blue
oh he's gone oh here here it comes
that's the supernova called supernova
isthmus - out there is there's old
signal and here's our new seeker that
many elements being formed in there
the dust that would but one day become
earth maybe this is the way it was
formed
[Music]
really liking these supernovae let's
have a look at them yes and just really
hot material all right well thanks for
watching me explode some mess and stars
using a black hole try this at home if
you can and see you next time